[Music]
my father was a lighthouse keeper
my mother was a queen but life is a way
of bringing people together
could unite our words one day check it
out
author is talking to the fish
they made me what I am
listen to come aboard
[Music]
I've been looking for you your half
brother King arm is about to declare war
upon the surface world
the only way to stop this war is for you
to take your rightful place as king
trust me I know you
you do your best thinking when you're
not thinking at all
that was the worst pep talk ever
I want to strap in
[Music]
my brother has come from the service
challenge me for the throne
I call it an ass-whooping
no leader
because I have no choice
I can save my home
the people who love you think you're
unreachable lead because you're of two
different worlds
that is exactly why you are worthy
coming to the surface
and I'm bringing the wrath of the seven
seas with me
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got to
break down this Aquaman footage I call
that an ass-whooping so there's just so
much stuff going on here so we just go
through his shot-by-shot but they're
kind of selling you on the Indiana Jones
Romancing the Stone vibe the James Bond
was talking about so obviously you have
the Aquaman mera
romance going on to the background
because she'll eventually become queen
of Atlantis but the main idea of the
film is that Aquaman has to find the
original trident that was wielded by at
land so that he can unite the seven seas
against or and stopped the war with the
surface world that orme is trying to
precipitate during the film so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the comic-con
videos I'll post my Shazam trailer in a
little while too I was in the middle of
working on that one this drop
so Warner Brothers is just like the
trailer fairy just dropping footage left
and right today the trailer just starts
out with a version of his origin story
how his mother played by Nicole Kidman
found his father
the lighthouse also ran out of the
comics too this is basically the place
where he grows up as a child you may
also recognize that his father's being
played by Jango Fett from Star Wars also
Boba Fett and all the clones from Clone
Wars because they're all a clone of this
one person they said the film would
explain why his mother did have to go
back to Atlantis but you have to imagine
that Atlantis is the capitol of the
seven different kingdoms because
Atlantis is the name of the city which
looks fantastic but it's also the name
of the nation that's made up of the
seven different kingdoms like they say
unites the seven so you have to imagine
that it's pretty volatile political
situation between the seven different
kingdoms because they all have their own
different kings that all have their
different agendas alka man's mother was
Queen at the time so she had to take the
throne to keep everything from boiling
over and prevent a war with the surface
world that later orme her other son
Aquaman's half-brother tries to bring
about so if you don't know the story
behind how Oram and aquaman her brothers
so you see in the beginning of the
trailer she falls in love with the human
they have a child that's Aquaman then
she's forced to go back because she has
to be Queen Atlantis would fall apart
without a ruler so she's forced to marry
in Atlantean because it's just their
custom she has a child with that person
that boy was armed so he grows up to be
the heir to the throne but because
Aquaman is the firstborn son he's the
true heir but he doesn't want to have
anything to do with Atlantis because
Atlantis views him as a half-breed
you're less than nothing the surface
world thinks he's a freak you get that
with a lot of these flashbacks when he's
a child like he's in the aquarium and
all the sharks and the fish start to
mass behind him just freaking all the
other kids out the other really big
thing here too is you see a version of
black mantas origin story so the whole
big scene where he jumps into the
submarine permission to come aboard and
takes them all out that's Black Manta
and his father's crew I'm guessing that
he ends up killing black mantas father
inadvertently that's probably why Manta
swears revenge but James Wan did say
that Manta gets his comic book costume
that we see later in the trailer which
is totally badass from Atlantean
technology given to him by orme so
obviously orme doesn't care about the
surface world he doesn't really care
about black manta but he's trying to
play both sides against each other so
he's trying to get people from the
surface world who will do anything to
kill Aquaman to do his dirty work for
him while he's also massing the seven
different kingdoms that you see all
messed up here you see a bunch of the
Atlanteans riding sharks these people
riding the seahorses are the forces of
Zeb oh so that's where Mira's from her
father is played by Dolph Lundgren he's
playing nearest from the comics this is
actually what does helmet looks like
it's a pretty good shot of it but you
also get a better shot of the people
from trench which is just total Creature
from the Black Lagoon you get a look at
the people of Bryan which is one of the
other kingdoms there the crustacean
looking people like I've talked about in
my other videos when Atlantis sank about
five thousand years ago the seven
different kingdoms evolved in different
ways some devolved the people that
devolved were the ones that live in
trench so that's why they look so crazy
they explained that Atlanteans can't
travel there it actually hurts Aquaman
to swim down there at that pressure
depth but the other people like the
Fisher King here which is played by John
and Han soo who appears as the wizard
during the Shazam trailer which I'll
talk about later today they evolve to
become more aquatic like so that's why
they fully look like more people but the
big MacGuffin is the comic book Trident
that belonged to at land so they
explained that the Quinn dent that he's
been wielding since Batman V Superman
belonged to his mother so if you ever
wondered why it's not classic comic book
yet it's because this belonged to his
mother they're searching for the one
that belonged to the original
King who's Aquaman's ancestor and that's
who you're seeing right here they have a
vision of him during the film this is
like the Indiana Jones treasure hunt
aspect of the movie that's how we get to
the path of him getting his comic book
armor which you get a pretty good shot
of in this promo art here so this is
what he's going to look like at the end
of the film in whatever sequels that he
pops up in this is them doing their
trial by combat I know Jason Momoa Khal
Drogo Game of Thrones may call the Game
of Thrones jokes that you want but this
is happening near in active volcano
that's why you see this hot lava in the
background but we got to talk about the
way they're doing the special effects
here so this is what it looks like when
they're underwater I think it's a much
better version than what we saw during
Justice League because they can just
talk to each other you don't have to
worry about the air bubbles the funny
thing they said to is when they were
shooting this is that the actors were
dry because when you're underwater you
don't actually look wet when they film
scenes where mera does have to create
air bubbles though and there's air
passing over them they had to hose the
actors down so fun filmmaking fact when
all these scenes were happening when
they're like finding each other all the
actors were dry and they just tuned
everything up with special effects a
little bit because they wanted to make
him feel like a badass and everybody
points to the Aquaman riding his sea
horses being really silly they wanted to
make him feel really cool they gave him
a dragon to ride during the film so Khal
Drogo finally gets a dragon but only in
the Aquaman movie but you had to imagine
that once he does get his comic book
armor and the Trident of Poseidon or at
land whatever they're going to call it
during the film there are multiple
Triton's that he wheels in the comics
that'll be even more opie so that yeah
he definitely is the most powerful
person on the planet as long as he's
near water but let me know in the
comments what you think about the look
of the movie what you think about the
feel of the characters and the fact that
they're reusing some music from the
previous DC films I think that's to give
it a sense of continuity but this is
taking place after the events of Justice
League my Shazam trailer should be up in
a little while so just look out for that
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should see everything
click here for that video I'll update
the link when I post it and click here
to learn all about the venom footage
from last night - thank you so much for
watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]